hey this is presto Walker if the last
digit of this number becomes the first
digit the resulting number is exactly
twice as large my number is the smallest
number with this property what is my
number now you might try and brainstorm
some examples which are close if you
take 25 and make the last digit of the
number the first digit you end up with
52 and this is close to being double 25
but it is not exactly 25 times 2 you
could also think about a three-digit
number like 102 if you take the last
digit of the number and make it the
first digit you end up with the result
which is close but not exactly double
102 so what is my number can you figure
it out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution one way we can solve this
puzzle is to set up a multiplication
problem we'll imagine multiplying an
original number by 2 in the standard
multiplication algorithm we'll write a
to be the last digit of the number and
that means a will be the first digit of
the resulting number now what value of a
can we test out we want a to be as small
as possible because we want the smallest
number which will satisfy the property
if the resulting number has the same
number of digits then a cannot be 0 and
we might also suspect that it has to be
an even number in the next method I'm
going to prove to you that it has to be
the lowest value of a equals 2 so for
now let's go ahead and just try a equals
2 so let's work through this
multiplication we have 2 times 2 which
is equal to 4 now the result actually
tells us
something even more useful the digits of
the resulting number are the same digits
as the original number that are shifted
over by one spot so each resulting digit
is the next digit in the original number
so this four will actually be the tens
digits in the original number we can
continue the multiplication four times
two is equal to eight that will be the
next digit in our original number now
when we try and do the multiplication we
run into some trouble eight times two is
equal to sixteen this is a two-digit
answer and we need to know what the next
digit will be so what we'll do is
something very similar to the regular
multiplication algorithm we're only
going to retain the unit's digit of six
and then we're going to carry over the
one just like in a regular
multiplication so eight times two is
equal to sixteen but we're going to
split that up into one which we carry
over and six which would keep as that
digit now this means that six will come
the next digit in our original number
now when we do this next multiplication
there will be many steps involved six
times two is equal to twelve this again
is a two-digit number so we're going to
take that one and carry it over but we
also have one from before that we're
going to need to carry over to make
their team so let's see how this works
we have six times two which is equal to
twelve so we now take the one that's
carried over from before and net becomes
thirteen we now need to take care of
this 13 so we're going to carry over the
one and we're going to keep the three
this three becomes the next digit of the
original number so now we'll covered
many of the cases of how we can continue
in this method and we're just going to
keep continuing this process until we
get to the number two with no carryover
at that point the digits will start
repeating so
we'll need to continue to go on so if
you do that I'm going to skip some steps
and just get to the answer we end up
with an 18 digit number that's 105
quadrillion 263 trillion 157 billion
eight hundred ninety four million seven
hundred and thirty six thousand eight
hundred and forty-two this is a solution
if we move the last digit to to the
first digit of the number the result is
exactly twice as large so this is the
answer but how do we know this is the
smallest number that works so this proof
was a little bit of hand wavy and now
I'm going to show you exactly why this
is the smallest number so in the next
method we're going to set up an algebra
equation well write a for the last digit
of the number just as before and then
we'll write B for the rest of the digits
and the number so we're going to say B
is a number with M digits this means our
original number can be written as 10
times B plus a we're shifting over the
number B so that we leave room for a as
the last digit to make a the first digit
of the new number it needs to be shifted
over m spots now Anna standard number we
multiply by 10 to shift over by one spot
we multiply by a hundred which equals 10
squared to shift over by two spots so
now we need to multiply by 10 to the
power of M to shift over by M spots this
means our new number can be written as
10 to the power of M times a plus B and
this has to equal 2 times the original
number so we have 2 times the original
number is equal to 10 to the power of M
times a plus B now let's simplify this
equation we distribute the two so we
have 20 B plus 2a we're then going to
subtract out minus B from both sides and
minus 2a from both sides we then factor
the right-hand side with the term 2a
we finally divide by 19 so we get an
expression for what B could possibly be
now B has to be a whole number
this means 19 has to be a factor of one
of the terms in the numerator but 19 is
not effecter of 2 and it cannot be a
factor of a because a is a digits that's
9 or smaller that means the 19 has to be
a factor of the other term which is 5
times 10 to the power of n minus 1 all
subtracted by 1 in other words we need
to solve for the smallest value M so
that the number 5 times 10 to the power
of M minus 1 leaves the remainder of 1
when divided by 19 now if you were to
just try and put this in a calculator or
a spreadsheet the numbers would get
astronomically large as you increment
the variable M so it's not going to work
out you're going to get an error when
you do this division you're not going to
be able to figure it out so what we're
going to need to do is we're going to
use modulo arithmetic which will keep
the number small and make the
calculations manageable so here's how we
can do that we're going to try and
figure out the remainder of 5 times 10
to the power of M minus 1 the first case
is easy where M equals 1 we just end up
with 5 and that's obviously 5 modulo 19
now how do we get M equals 2 well rather
than calculate out the whole number what
we can do is we're going to take 10
times the previous remainder and then
simplify so we take 10 times 5 because 5
was the previous remainder that equals
50 and then we simplify that that is
remainder of 12 so for N equals 2 we
have 12 mod 19 now to do M equals 3 we
again multiply the previous results by
10 so we take 10 times 12 which is 120
and then we simplify that to get to be 6
for the next term we would take 10 times
6 and so on this can be done in a
spreadsheet very quickly and we're going
to need to keep going until we get to a
remainder 1
so this happens when M is equal to 17 so
possibly we're looking at B being a 17
digit number so if B is a 17 digit
number and one more digit appended for a
in all we have an 18 digit number now if
we try a equals one to be the smallest
value of a we actually end up with a 16
digit value for B and that leads to a 17
digit number and that's not a solution
you can actually check if you take the
last digit and move it to the front it's
not a solution so we're going to try the
next possible smallest value would be a
equals 2 in that case we do get a
solution we do end up with a 17 digit
number for B and that leads to the 18
digit number that is the answer
this is 105 quadrillion 263 trillion 157
billion eight hundred ninety four
million seven hundred thirty six
thousand eight hundred forty two and it
does have this property did you figure
this out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blogs mind your decisions
if you can follow on Facebook Google+ as
a picture on you can catch me on social
media app for soccer and if you like
this video please check out my books
there are links in the video description